the Trump administration is currently
reviewing this little controversial but
they're reviewing a list of 27 national
monuments to decide if they should
continue to receive funding this is a
real story there it is 27 national
monuments under Interior Department
review and they may have a point I
looked into it there are a lot of
incredible monuments in the u.s. we know
that but there are others that may not
deserve Monument status for example
there's birthplace of Survivor season
one winner Richard Hatch a Newport Rhode
Island yeah there's this one floating
island of soy sauce packets off the
coast of Santa Cruz California yeah I'm
not sure about the seth rogen National
Forest in Woodland Hills California
there's the Museum of toilets destroyed
by President Taft Cincinnati Ohio 155
toilets ladies gentleman here's the
deform tree that looks like a butt when
you're high in Boulder Colorado and
that's a good one yeah that's a good one
and finally Idaho crop circles that
spell out was up that's Ben
you
you